good day everyone
a very warm welcome to this webinar
titled
storytelling and design for emotions
this session is presented by the design
singapore council
in partnership with cadenze a platform
for creative learning online
and the maryland institute college of
art
the session is also supported by the
national design center
and is part of the centre's emotive
design
program lineup for the month of march
2021
today's webinar consists of mainly two
portions
we will be starting off with a sharing
session by our speaker
before ending with a q a segment
moderated by
narelle yabuka from dsg where you will
be able to ask questions
and have an interactive time with us
in the spotlight today we have miss
ellen lotten
ellen is a graduate faculty at the
maryland institute college of art
in baltimore where she has authored
numerous books on design processes
she also serves as the senior curator of
contemporary design
at cooper hewitt smithsonian design
museum in new york city
without further ado i will now pass the
time over to ellen
who will be taking you through today's
session
ellen please hello it's so great to see
you all it's wonderful to be in
singapore tonight
i'm really excited to talk to you
about storytelling and emotions
the content that i'm going to share
comes from
these two books that were published by
cooper hewitt smithsonian design museum
but they also come from my teaching
at micah and you can see me here on the
stage with my wonderful colleague rocket
horn
where we love to teach our students in
person
and and live but this year we've been
teaching online
and actually micah has been
experimenting with online teaching for
several years and developing content
that we can share with people
all over the world so today's talk
some of the ideas can also be found in
in more depth and more varieties
and more topics in a class that brockett
and i
offer online at cadenze called graphic
design history and methods
so you can join us there as well if you
are interested
so today i'm going to talk about
storytelling
which is my favorite subject and i love
this
because as graphic designers we really
want to engage
people we want to engage their emotions
we want to engage their sense of empathy
we want to create a feeling of action
and agency for the people looking at our
work
or using our work and storytelling is a
perfect
medium for doing those things it's our
most
ancient universal form of expression
and what i'm going to do tonight is take
you through
some of the principles that are
universal
to stories but ground them
in design practice and we're going to
look
at a lot of things together i'm going to
ask you to look at
some things in in the chat
if you like um we'll do that
soon so uh the first
principle i want to share with you is
the idea of point of view
so every story has a point of view
character and we're familiar with this
from movies and novels that we
experience the world through the point
of view of our hero
and in graphic design designers have
developed
various ways to kind of bring us
inside the psychological experience
of a character one of my favorite
mediums for looking that at that are
film posters and theater posters
because they have to represent the
psychological
conflict of a story
through a single image so this beautiful
polish
film poster uses a very simple
collage technique uh to suggest
the interior life of this individual
and we we can really feel a sense of
entering into his mind
experiencing him in relation to a
landscape
and a city and a time and a place
and these are techniques that designers
can
can use so this is a poster that uses a
very simple
montage technique um to take us
inside the mind of a of a person
and that's something that you as
designers can try
in your work now you see a poster called
tartuffe
a black and yellow poster and at the
center of the
of the image is a very tall man with a
tv
for a head um and he's surrounded by a
crowd
and these smaller people are looking up
at him
and really we're in their point of view
we are looking at this uh this figure
this
uh tv evangelist uh figure who's
commanding our attention
and we're essentially have joined the
crowd we have the point of view of the
crowd
and so this idea of manipulating
perception and psychology
and showing who is a hero in an
image and who is a spectator who is a
witness
um i want to take a moment to ask
you all to look at this poster
an incredible film poster from
switzerland
and it shows a scene um
um a a dinner scene hopefully not
from from your house and
the father is the point of view
character
right he is the the main figure
um in the scene and i want you to just
take a look at the poster
and type a few words in the chat what
connects us emotionally with the father
what has the designer done to ensure
that we are empathetic with him we are
concerned about his position
we identify with him and we don't
identify with anybody else right we're
cut off from them
emotionally so i see he is the only face
that we see
right and so if the designer had simply
used the photograph
as it existed we might feel more
connected to the other
characters and so blocking their faces
helps to intensify our connection with
the father
and also creates incredible visual play
and fun um so we get this graphic
excitement that also has a psychological
emotional function and that's really key
to us
in graphic design is how can we create
an image that is exciting and fresh and
has
visual components i see breaking the
fourth wall
escaping right he wants to escape but he
can't
because he's wearing a leash which is
very alarming
and he's looking to us for help right
he's um he's reaching out to us
emotionally
this is a very famous poster on the
screen now
by milton glacier his dylan poster of
1968 in our
collection at cooper hewitt all these
posters are from our collection
um and then this very famous poster
milton glacier
brings us inside the mind
of bob dylan and by turning his hair
into this rainbow of color
he um suggests the music
the imagination the thoughts
of the singer right and if we pull back
we see his face is dark his face has
really no emotion no features we're
brought
inside right we're brought into his
interior experience
and here's an example from more
contemporary design this is a beautiful
brand illustration for medium
and by trying to convey the experience
of this
young woman reading an article on medium
the artist has used simple collage
and opened up her head and growing from
her head
is life right the life of ideas
and throughout the the branding of the
site
the the designers create these kind of
images
that attempt to convey to us the
experience of reading
um and how oh how opening that is right
that to read something
is really to open your mind and then
there are moments of reward
right that are not so much about reading
but are about becoming a member
right and and rewarding us for that
achievement right for
um for joining the team being part of
the team
um and so we can see some you know
repetition of techniques
right and as designers uh we all
collect things to look at we all seek
inspiration
in history and in film and contemporary
life
and so i like to see how some of these
concepts
recur another really important
idea about stories is the idea of a path
uh that every story takes us
somewhere um it has duration
it has beginning middle and end okay
and now we see two pictures
okay two pictures of the forest and
spring and if you could just put
a note in the in the path
in the chat sorry
um
okay i see a lot of people sing sing be
and i agree with you
and i love to know why yes we seem to go
somewhere right and
these are images with a path and if you
go to the next one
yes great so just putting an image of a
road
starts to invite action it suggests
motion and time
and a point of view right suddenly we
are a person standing on that path
so point of view in the sense of what am
i looking at
next slide and if you
google big picture of forest which i did
you will find that many of these images
these are the most popular images
have some kind of path or stream
or a dominant tree or two dominant trees
having a conversation together
that these are the kinds of images that
people find more narrative
they find them more inviting
because they have the the most basic
indication of of a story of a narrative
you go to the next slide
this is another poster from our amazing
collection at cooper hewitt is by e
mcknight coffer who was
a designer in the early 20th century and
he's created a path
in this travel poster to invite us to
travel
next and if we come in close
we are rewarded by baby mushrooms and
light
and shadow it's a journey right the
poster takes us
on a journey next
um this is a later poster by the same
um artist when he's discovered futurism
and this poster is more abstract it's
more modern
and yet it has the same technique
it has a path that carries
us into the future and the future is
a motorcycle next slide
i love this detail right which gives us
this
climax of the story right this story
is is a line that takes us
to this event next
so every story has duration and if we
think about the poster right a poster is
a flat image and yet the way we absorb
it
just like any book cover or website or
page of text
our eye has to travel across the piece
and as designers we can kind of control
or guide a visitor a viewer
in and taking that journey and taking a
journey that we helped design
for them next so this is an illustration
by one of my favorite visual artists
christophe nieman
and we're looking at the top of the
image
and when you come to the bottom you can
go to the next slide
we have a story right so at the top of
the image
we see someone hanging laundry
very boring but at the bottom
we have the punch line we have the event
um and even though we look at this image
very quickly
it still takes time it takes maybe a
second
for this story to unfold so i'm going to
show you another image by
christophe niemann and we're just going
to look at the top
so just show the next slide and leave it
there
okay so here are two hands knitting
and i want you to just take a moment and
guess
what are the hands knitting ah and i see
some people have guessed it correctly go
to the next slide
it's the eiffel tower i'm very impressed
i would have thought a pair of socks
right because i'm just thinking in the
ordinary world
but what this visual storytelling does
is it brings us
a surprising world it brings us a climax
to the story
uh yes very french thank you
go ahead you go to the next slide um
this is a beautiful mural in paris
posted during the spring of 2020.
better days are coming soon and this
mural
is a path here's a path that we
literally
experience over time we have to walk
through it to get the message next
this is a a beautiful project um also
from the spring
of 2020 a a graphic
created in the town of vitio in northern
italy
for social distancing and the architects
who created this
painted these white squares
in the town center to help people
gather together in public and yet keep
distance from each other
next
and they posted throughout the village
these beautiful graphics
explaining what the purpose was of this
new
signage that they had created and what
you'll see from that grid
is that the squares aren't all the same
size
and so they have created this variation
that's very spatial
and that really references the history
of perspective
in northern italy where linear
perspective
painting was invented next
and we can get that beautiful sense of
space
that sense of point of view that sense
of perspective
in this gorgeous piece which was beloved
by the town
and really helped people during this
crisis
to experience public space in a safe way
next
and all over the world people have been
creating
beautiful or just functional graphics
for social distancing
this is paula shares design for the
highline park
in new york city where she put these
beautiful green
dots on the walkways of the park but
also on the furniture
um to create a really playful and joyful
reminder for people to keep their
distance
next
um and here's where you had to wait in
line
to visit the park so in order to control
the number of people
at the high line they created a ticket
system
um and even that has its beautiful green
dots
to keep people organized and patient
while they wait to visit the park
next another really important thing
about stories is action stories are not
passive uh stories have events
and conflict and things taking place
next um so this is another beautiful
poster
by joseph mueller brockman from the
cooper hewick collection
and it's a poster about traffic
accidents
and about warning you to watch out for
children on the street
and the designer by greatly amplifying
the scale difference
between the vehicle and the child gives
us a much greater sense of action
than we would have if the photographs
were simply allowed to be at
actual scale so that's a you know a
basic
technique for graphic designers to
enhance that
sense of urgency in something happening
the
angle is very important too next
so here's a poster by emic knight coffer
about
tea and how tea wakes us up
and makes us feel good in the afternoon
and he's put the poster
the type on an angle and that angle
really helps to create that sense of
activation that we get from t
so i had fun i kind of redid the poster
without the angle and if you go to the
next slide you can see it
and it's very boring right and if you
flip back
between them is kind of amusing yeah she
kind of winks
right my simple animation and of course
the poster is
much better the way the designer made it
with the angle
um and that's really a universal
technique for suggesting
action and movement because things could
be slipping and sliding
and in play next
go ahead next slide
sometimes designers convey action quite
literally through a series of images
as in this wonderful vignelli poster
um where we we see the dancer moving and
we see him moving towards the climax of
the action
right the height of the drama is where
the dancer is highest
in the air and perhaps vignelli pushed
him a little higher
than he actually was right to increase
that sense of action
next and also
in advertising and an editorial design
we can create a series like in a comic
book i love this one
for casper mattress
and it's illustrating the idea of
breakfast
in bed something we may all wish we
could do
more often but here the story line is
that
it's literally the coffee and the bagel
getting into bed together
to enjoy breakfast next
and of course for designers sometimes
we're telling stories
about products we're telling stories
about user experience
that may not be the end result of our
work
but rather the process of describing
what people need right what users might
experience so this is a beautiful
storyboard by the designer menyon lee
and she's describing the um the
experience of a commuter with a bike
who wants to get on a bus but the bus
has no room for their bike
and and the commuter ends the experience
very sad
right and so this presents a design
challenge it presents
um us with a an emotional experience
right
the disappointment of this commuter
and identifies a challenge that
designers of transportation then might
try to address
next so storyboarding is a really
valuable
tool for us it's also something that we
see
a lot in website design now
where an action or a process
is broken down into one two three
parts beginning middle end as
a way to invite people to say
try out the service become a member
sign up experience something
understand what the service is and by
simplifying a much longer process
into three steps um it helps people to
really
grasp the simplicity of the action and
illustrate it through these
these three phases next
and so we see this number three a lot
um in stories in in design
and instructions um because people have
um
a great ease in grasping the idea of
three
so in this poster about social
distancing
the designer has chosen three kind of
archetypal
characters who might be at risk for
covid19
and we're able to kind of understand
their humanity and understand them
as a range of people and yet that number
is manageable um so so writers call this
the rule of threes
it's very valuable for us as designers
as well
next slide um
writers and filmmakers talk about
the narrative arc so when you're
planning
uh a story a work of fiction film
a episode of a tv show the idea
of an arc that begins at a low point of
energy
that sets a problem that creates a
scenario
and then as the story builds the energy
gets higher and higher
we can think of it like a roller coaster
when you get on a roller coaster at the
beginning you're low
and you're literally building energy
physical energy
as the car moves up the
the side of the roller coaster and at
the top
is the point of maximum tension
maximum energy and then
you come down the other side and that's
the sense of completion
and so a really satisfying story has
that
whole arc of energy including that sense
at the end
of having completed something one two
three i'm done i'm in
i've achieved it next slide
and designers use tools like the
narrative arc
and user experience design and planning
what is the experience of a user
in encountering a product or a service
and often we we chart that in terms of
negative and positive experiences
so where will a user encounter a dip
in the action right friction
a problem having to wait
not being able to find what they need a
point of confusion
and this is a very valuable tool for
designers and it is a storytelling tool
where we imagine this rising and falling
emotional experience of a user next
so every story is an emotional journey
we go to a
place things happen but we feel things
when they happen next
this is a beautiful diagram by an
exhibition designer
ben jett and he uses this diagram to
show
intensity so that in an exhibition
which is a physical journey right
through a place
there are points of emotional intensity
and a designer plans for like what will
be the long view
um where will a visitor be expected to
have
the greatest reaction and where do we
need them to rest
where do people need a break right a
white space a gap
a bench these are very important for the
experience of our users
next slide so this is the same designer
applying this principle to the design
of an exhibition about the american
civil war
which is an extremely emotional topic in
our country
and as you can see this exhibition has a
lot of hot spots
right a lot of areas where people are
going to be
overwhelmed and confronted with very
intense information
so it's important then to build in those
gaps you can go to the next one
so ikea is another emotional journey
um i imagine that many of you have been
to ikea
and have journeyed there and when i when
i first went to ikea i thought
this is like a maze right
but then i started doing research and i
discovered that
ikea is not really a maze next
it's a labyrinth okay
so a maze is is a puzzle
designed to make you lost
and a labyrinth uh is actually a fixed
path where my my motion is controlled
through the space
and so if you think about designing a
book or a website or an exhibition
sometimes we allow our users complete
freedom
but they might get lost and sometimes we
have a very fixed path
but like a movie is a six path you can
only go forward
right but a book i can flip around in
the book and get lost if i want
so let's take a little trip through ikea
next
um so we leave the parking lot
and we we enter the world of ikea and
we're like a hero
right we're on the hero's journey we
enter this magical
branded space where everything is
designed
right and it is a fixed path right we
are told which way to go
next and eventually we
go downstairs where we are confronted
with
lots more stuff uh next
and inside the store there is literally
a path
right it has different paving on it it
has an edge around it it has
light projected arrows reminding us to
keep going on
the path next
and the path goes on and there are
scenes and events
like almost theatrical plays right where
we encounter this
perfect kitchen for example next
there are secret passages for escaping
the path
if you know how next
um and then finally we gather all our
materials
we we pay the money
we put everything in the shopping bags
that we have had to bring
with us next and at the end
there is a hot dog at least at my ikea
it may be a different
food in singapore but this hot dog
is so cheap they're paying me
to eat it and this hot dog is to save my
life
right because i i'm so glad that you
have these wonderful hot dogs i think
the veggie hot dog is quite
quite good and i am so grateful for this
hot dog because at this point i am
exhausted and if i didn't have that hot
dog
i would die like jack nicholson in the
maze at the end of the shining
right this is savior and it is an
emotional gift to me from ikea
next so let's apply this to a famous
fairy tale the story of cinderella and
imagine cinderella as a customer
experience
next so at the beginning of the story
her emotional state is very low she
has nothing to wear she can't go to the
ball she has a miserable life
so what does she do she downloads the
fairy godmother app
next next
and this is fantastic great product love
it
next and
cinderella is giving this product you
know lots of stars
lots of thumbs up she loves the dress
she loves the carriage she loves the
party
there's just one problem next
ah curfew something bad's gonna happen
at midnight
next so cinderella is at the party
and she's having a great time and
it's almost midnight and she knows she's
got to get back to that
carriage or it's going to turn into a
pumpkin and she's running down the steps
and she loses one of these stupid glass
slippers on her way
but she almost makes it next
and it's 11 59 and we know what happens
at midnight next
at least where i am the most popular
times to travel
you have to pay more we call it surge
pricing
and this is terrible cinderella hates it
next
and now she's pissed right no more lovin
a fairy godmother ass so
the designers back at fairy
godmother.com they're like what are we
going to do
to bring cinderella's emotions back up
and they come up with this great thing
which is
a lost and found service so they
they find out cinderella's address they
violate her privacy they come to her
house they bring her that slipper
and we all know how the story ends it's
very satisfying it gives us a beautiful
sense of completion
next she gets her shoe back
and opens her own shoe store
and is financially independent ever
after
i wish it ended like that so emotion
sometimes the emotions that we have to
convey
aren't happy ones right so we're in a
very tough time now there's a lot going
on in my country this
pandemic is still very tough it's
getting better but it's very tough
and so this is a graphic created by our
centers for disease control
um about covid symptoms and it really
tries to remove the emotions
right so like not giving the people any
facial expression or any faith
right is a way to literally erase
emotions from this poster
maybe that's a good idea i don't know
next
this is um the same content presented by
the amazing designer mona chalabi
and she's decided to go for the emotions
and to communicate to people about the
reality of suffering
and to do it in a way that is playful
and warm and humane
but doesn't eliminate
that sense of emotional urgency
next
finally i want to talk about our senses
and this is my last little chapter
so we've talked about the path we've
talked about
agency action we've talked about
point of view which is very important
whose point of view is the story told
from
and finally there's our senses so really
good
stories uh engage our senses
we feel like we've gone someplace uh we
feel that we we're being touched
right physically we feel that we feel
the warmth
of a story we feel the coldness of the
story these are emotions
that writers create with words that
filmmakers create
with with movement right sudden movement
with music
right which which elevates our sense of
emotion through a purely
audio soundtrack and as visual designers
we can play with people's senses
too next
um so here's another another little
project
for you to do very quickly is here are
some shampoo
shampoo and conditioner bottles from my
bathroom
and i want you to pick a or b which one
do you think is better designed i see a
lot of a's
i see some b's i say it's pretty equal
but somebody said b because i would get
them confused
and that's exactly what how i feel about
this because as you might
notice i wear glasses and i don't wear
them
in the shower and when i see these two
bottles
a they look exactly the same
it's just that little bit of typography
that's different
whereas b the entire shape of the bottle
is different and even with my glasses
off i can figure out which one is which
now imagine if you were blind in the
shower
you would really need to have that
tactile signal
to know which product to use yeah so
next
here's another one which one do you
think was designed to appeal to women
a or b i see a lot of people doing b
i think you're absolutely right you go
to the next slide
they actually have the same amount of
beer in them
but by making the bee the second one
thinner it feels smaller in your hand
and many women have smaller hands not
all
and it looks thinner right so it appeals
to our sense
of drinking a light product that has
fewer calories
and then my favorite part of all is that
the whole surface is reflective
right so whereas the a has dark green
all over it by having this kind of naked
aluminum on the second product it's
light in the sense of light
right light reflecting so it's a very
subtle effect but i really think it
affects our experience of the product
and what i find so remarkable is the mix
of visual and tactile cues
right how does it feel in my hand how do
i
think it will feel right how much will
it weigh
what is its lightness physically and
then the idea of light
reflecting someone's pointed out it's
like a silver jewel
it really is elegant and it's just a can
of beer
next and of course we use
uh color to convey
a sense of um of taste and smell
so this is a beautiful line of tea
packages
and the t inside the package
all looks pretty much the same right
it's very similar
but by giving each box its own
distinct color the designer begins to
create this
signal for us about the relative
lightness or richness or
floral aspect of each flavor of tea
next and we can do this with
products that aren't intended to be
eaten at all
this is a line of polaroid cameras
called the ice cream pastels edition
and so by using these colors that have a
sensory
memory for us the designers have
have made this a desirable and fun and
playful
kind of summertime experience next
there's a beautiful project by one of my
students at micah
it's a game about digestion
so this lovely river that you see is
actually the river
inside your intestines and
in her game um she has you know healthy
food
and the intestines are in a healthy
state and everybody's happy and it looks
quite
sunny inside your gut but when things go
wrong
next the whole mood
changes and so this simple shift
in color palette creates an entire
emotional transformation in your
experience of the game
next and this is the kobit 19 map
from johns hopkins university where that
color red
is used to convey urgency and the
seriousness of this problem
next whereas this map
um it's a map of chicago
showing that high prevalence of
healthcare workers
in a particular neighborhood in chicago
and here the designer
didn't want to use red because they
didn't want to convey
a negativity to this data and so color
they deliberately chose the color purple
because it doesn't have that emotional
connection that emotional weight to it
next i think we're almost done
i picked this out because it has a nice
connection to singapore
this is a project by kate mclean who
does
smell tours of different cities and she
takes people through the city
experiencing
what different areas smell like and so
she's created this wheel
to represent the different flavors
and what i want you to notice is that
she doesn't
she doesn't want to make any of them
negative so you'll see there's beautiful
things like flowers and trees
but there's also garbage and animal
manure and she uses color
to suggest that these are simply
experiences
for people to take note of in their
sensory tour of the city
and we'll go to the next slide which is
a beautiful map of singapore
where she took people through through
the city and found
areas that had these different densities
of smells and it becomes a different way
to think about space
and using color as a way to trigger our
memory
of those experiences is really cool
go to the next um so now let's look at
storytelling and action
we're going to look at how one designer
applied storytelling
across an entire project next
so eden lew is a graphic designer who
was
asked to create a logo for an
organization
called the last mile next slide
and this organization is a volunteer
group that delivers
masks and protective equipment to
healthcare workers
and so eden designed this beautiful logo
and the logo is a path it shows
a road and the road has an intersection
and together they make a cross which is
a symbol for healthcare so the client
loved it and it was very clear and
helped them to
announce their service and use it as
stickers and
website and all kinds of things that
they needed a logo
for for but then eden wondered
what else does the organization need
next
so she saw that they had these very
complex
diagrams explaining the process
of collecting and delivering
protective equipment and these are
clearly designed
with a kind of engineering point of view
and they show
all the steps and all the complexity
of the core function of the organization
but eden thought hmm i could design this
to tell a much simpler story next
and so she made this graphic which is
more for the
volunteers to understand exactly what
the organization
does it's not the back end it's the
front end
it's the interface it's the simple how
to
to encourage people to get involved with
this organization
next and in order to create that
timeline
she created a whole family of icons
working with illustrators and if we look
at these icons
they are like illustrations in a story
they show the people being served
they show the emergency workers they
show
people doing things like riding a bike
there's a path right a representation of
a road
with drop off points along the road
and they're very simple very direct we
talked about simplicity
today in the talk so that simplicity
makes these icons very effective and
very clear
next but eden
also created these illustrations which
are much more
active and much more emotional
they bring us into a scene we have a
sense of
air moving and atmosphere and we have a
sense of the people the volunteers and
the emergency workers
doing their very heroic work that they
do
and so all those levels of storytelling
are brought together
in this piece from the logo that tells
the story
to the icons to the process chart
to these much more experiential
illustrations
next and so just to conclude
these are some of the principles that we
talked about today and these are
principles that are universal to
storytelling
whether you're creating graphic design
or directing a movie
or writing a novel right stories have a
point of view
a story is a path a story has
action a story engages us
emotionally this is really important we
feel emotionally connected
and stories engage our senses
and so those are some some principles
that you can take
and apply to your design work whether
you're creating a poster
a book cover a service an app
storytelling is a set of tools that you
can use
so thank you so much for having me here
today
i really appreciate the opportunity to
talk with all of you
it was great to see how how much
laughter you brought to your
presentation thank you
and with that i'd like to go to a first
question which is about humor
do you think that designing with a sense
of humor is one of the winning factors
in making a product or a design stand
out among its competitors
i do i'm a huge fan of humor
i think humor makes people feel
feel good it also really helps to convey
the personality of a brand
that as soon as a brand or a product or
a service whatever it might be
starts being funny it actually undercuts
itself
a little bit and becomes more
approachable
it immediately becomes a conversation
with people
it's a type of engagement right when you
laugh
you are literally engaging and so i
think it's a very powerful tool and it's
something that designers can really
study
there's a lot of principles of humor uh
many books about it and you can really
uh
learn to math you know learn some of the
techniques some of the patterns it's
basically patterns
yeah thanks that's a great question yeah
it would be fun to
purposefully apply that throughout your
your career
okay well here's a bit of a more serious
one this one's about ethics
which is a great thing to talk about
what's your
view on what happens in the contemporary
world where manipulation is so present
not only of information but also of
images even
false images tell stories engage
attracts with a place in a time
and have a point of view do you see this
occurring on a
recurring basis both from the point of
view of the designer who uses
storytelling as a tool
as well as the viewer who's persuaded by
these devices
and in that case is the design
successful when using storytelling
that's a really great question and i
think
we have to ask that ethical question
about any kind of
messages that that we convey
when we're dealing with data graphics
you know that's a particularly sensitive
area
because people expect truth there
right that's not funny especially
yes and so that's why you know i was
showing the examples with using color
for
for example to amplify
an emotional reaction and in fact some
people have objected to that
covid19 map by jhu
for being alarmist you know but using
that color
red to show how bad things are
and if you look at you know other maps
of covid19
some of them are very pale and light and
gentle
and have been designed to make people
feel less
um alarmed and so right there is an
ethical question
like is downplaying the data
also manipulative you know so it's a
great question
um and i think it's something that we
have to confront
pretty much with every message right are
you telling the truth
are you telling the truth about the
service
can you really sign up in three steps
or is it really 20 steps bundled into
three
you know and at what point is making it
easier for a user
is good but at a certain point are you
are you telling a lie and that's bad
yeah
okay well here's one about um the nature
of audience
so design can be subjective it can be
interpreted and perceived differently by
different people
so how can we then get our story across
accurately to different audiences
um well that's a really great question
i mean some some communication is meant
to be for a very particular audience
right so
today i did a talk where i assumed that
we all knew what graphic design was
right
that i kind of came in with this base
knowledge
which if i were doing this talk for uh
doctors
who i i'll also have a book about design
for doctors i wouldn't assume that they
know anything
about graphic design um
so sometimes it's knowing the specific
needs of your audience if you're trying
to reach
everyone it's really important to be
redundant
because some people so some people can't
read
so you need to have a picture and a word
maybe you have the words in multiple
languages right you live in a
multilingual
culture
sometimes you need to have things be in
audio
and visual so this is a principle
of inclusive design and accessibility
that if i'm watching netflix i i can
turn on the captions
and then i can watch it with no sound
and that's helpful
to me but it's essential to a person who
can't hear
i can also turn on an audio track that
describes what's going on
and people aren't as familiar with that
but that helps someone who's blind
so this redundancy is important for
including everybody if you're trying to
do that
right okay well let me ask something
kind of similar but in a different way
um
do you think different eras of time can
be associated with different emotions on
a collective level
despite the differences that there might
be between social and cultural groups
and do do we see that emerging in the
design being produced at that time
well we certainly look back at certain
times with nostalgia
right i think we generally look at
history
through a very emotional lens and
certain periods we might
associate with terrible privation
and others with like the good old days
and the way it
you know when it was better right that's
a big problem in my country
is people imagining this this better
time that actually
was only better for some people
um does an entire era
have an emotion i don't think so because
i think i think that excludes a lot of
people
so we imagine an era as being
only the people in power the people who
are in movies or the people that novels
were written about
but actually there's you know millions
of people who aren't in those stories
okay um
there's been a few questions along these
lines when designing what's the best way
to decide whether we should keep
things simple sometimes a designer will
get feedback that things are too direct
or things are too difficult what's the
best way to keep things simple
i mean i generally want things to be
simple
and yet i write books where you know
every inch has
content on it because i don't want to
waste
any moments of like sharing my my love
with my reader
you know as a writer i spend a lot of
time simplifying
sentences i think generally
people really you know want things to be
easier
not harder and as
artists we sometimes go in the other
direction
because the things that are intricate
and complex
and layered are beautiful and fun to
make
and engaging to some audiences
but i think generally in life we don't
want to work too hard
so making things simple and clear i
think there's a real
a real plus for our users
okay i've got one for you about your
curatorial work here
what are some of the considerations you
apply to designing an exhibition for an
emotional journey
and how do you think about the balance
between emotional and learning
experiences
um that's a beautiful question most
people who go to a museum really don't
want to learn anything
right it's their day off it's if kids
are on a field trip
they really it's like their day out of
school
um so you have to privilege the
experience first
and then the learning is wrapped around
it
so the idea of joy and pleasure and a
place to sit
and a place to get coffee is really
important
and the knowledge and the scholarship is
important too
but you you have to create that
experience of pleasure
okay somebody asked about um how how to
apply storytelling to a visual identity
that's one of the most succinct forms of
communication
um that's a really great question my
last example was going to
show that yeah so
visual identity is is great for
storytelling so there's the
the logo which is typically a word right
logo type means
word um but we try to convey that word
in a way that suggests some emotion
right that the personality comes through
and then there's all the you know the
brand is not just the logo
it's that supporting language and is
that language warm or is it
authoritative
is it funny is it is it very serious
and then of course you know color which
creates a sensory
connection um
pattern languages which create sensory
and narrative elements uh
so so branding is is very much about
storytelling
and then we build in you know many
brands now want a kind of origin story
about how the brand came to be
especially with startups
but also like really venerable older
companies to
want to kind of convey that sense of
their own um
origin uh and that that's part of
uh branding for sure
are you okay to answer a few more we've
got a lot of people asking questions
okay thank you uh we have a
graduate graphic designer asking
about what to expect when entering the
industry and staying
driven and passionate from your point of
view on
engagement i guess through your work
what would you say to that person
you know you have to be engaged in your
work
but also in your life and so
staying engaged with the field of design
you know as a conversation among
peers all around the world is really
important coming to events like this
is part of that that you go to work
every day and you work for your clients
or you work for your colleagues
and that's really important right that's
that's the essence of
being in the design profession but that
you also stay engaged with the world
and um that's what you know museums and
exhibitions and zoom talks and
books you know all that stuff keeps
feeding your
your your mind workshops you know
great stuff to do thank you for your
contribution
in all of those regards sure somebody's
asking what would you consider
bad design or bad storytelling
well maybe we go to the ethical question
right
is if if we're lying to people that's
bad
um you know the example of ikea
and the maze versus the labyrinth
i think this is really you know a
question that
everyone should ask about whatever
project you're doing
are you creating a fixed path
or are you allowing people to wander
and there's not a right or wrong answer
but if people are allowed to wander will
they get stuck will they get lost
like i did in zoo
it was like terrifying right not to know
what was going on
um so if you're allowing people to
wander you have to give them the tools
and if you're putting them on a fixed
path
you also have to let them escape
but like what if they want to leave that
should be easy to leave
or go back and see something again
so i think with storytelling just really
being deliberate about what kind of
experience you're trying to create for
people and and what degree of freedom
is there in that experience
i have somebody who's designing a board
game
and that's a story yeah this um
audience member is a student of visual
communication design in turkey
yasa university thank you for your
question
working on redesigning a board game what
do you think is important in redesigning
a game
well the game has to be fun
and that's the game mechanics and
there's whole theories and books you can
read about that
so if the underlying game isn't fun it
doesn't matter how cool the money looks
or how cool the
spinning wheel is or any of that stuff
right all of that
is skin it's embellishment on the game
so if you're redesigning a game the
first thing i would do is like
make sure that the game is fun and is
there anything you can do to make it
more fun
like to raise the stakes and to make the
the play faster so people aren't waiting
for their turn
you know what are people doing while
they're waiting and then
do the like rebrand it and make
beautiful new graphics
good answer okay i i think we're we've
gone
over time and i don't want to keep
people from their days i'm going to end
up with just one last question
how do you know when a design is
complete how do you know when to stop
i never want to stop
when i do my projects whether it's a
book or an exhibition i just want to
keep
making it better you know so that's hard
but your user should know that you're
done right and this is that idea of the
experience
the story is a beginning middle end it
has a sense of completion
is people should feel like it's finished
like it's complete
um when you go to a restaurant you know
you want
that sense of having completed the
experience
and that when you you leave you you've
done something and you didn't spend the
whole time waiting or being frustrated
um so make sure they know you're done
even if you're not that's a great
message to end with
thinking about the audience and empathy
for your audience
thank you so much ellen and audience
thank you so much for all of your
wonderful questions ellen it's been a
real pleasure to host you thank you so
much
thanks narelle we hope to see you in
singapore at the national design center
sometime soon and to all of our audience
members as well
so thank you again and i'll take it back
to charlotte
thank you ladies and every one of you
who have joined us today
we have come to the end of our session
and we would appreciate it if you could
take some time
to share your feedback through a quick
survey by scanning the qr code on your
left
a link to the survey can also be found
in the zoom chat
let us know what type of future programs
you'd be interested to see
from the national design center and
lastly
if you would like to find out more about
the upcoming programs
the national design center has lined up
under the much thematic of emotive
design
do scan the qr code that you see on the
right
thank you once again for spending time
with us and we hope to see you
at our future events goodbye
you